[Musique]
cet endroit des femmes il est autorisé
depuis 1975 et la loi veille
[Musique]
et j'aimerais procéder en fait
en France une femme sur trois a recours
au moins une fois dans sa vie à
l'avortement de 120 000 interruptions
volontaires de grossesse sont pratiqués
chaque année un droit encore jugé et
stigmatisé moi j'ai eu un même personnel
soignant qui m'a énormément culpabilisé
en disant que bah si mon copain voulait
enfin me forcez pas à le garder c'est
que forcément il n'aimait pas que je
suis un être vivant que j'étais une
audience personne quoi c'est que les
gens gardent une vie négative de la
femme qui fait une interruption de
grossesse c'est surtout ça je pense
qu'il faut changer
endroit que ces opposants aimeraient
supprimer
[Musique]
comme aux États-Unis depuis qu'il n'est
plus garanti par la Cour suprême
[Applaudissements]
l'abolition de la loi belge
alors l'idée est née en France de le
constitutionnaliser pour mieux le
protéger en fait il faudrait inscrire
l'avortement comme un droit qui se
questionne pas
ça veut dire quelque chose qui fait
partie de la santé des femmes
en novembre dernier l'assemblée adoptait
à une large majorité l'inscription du
droit à l'avortement dans la
Constitution
collect je suis très très
de ce vote et de se signaler historique
que l'Assemblée nationale sonore a
envoyé à toutes les femmes de notre pays
mais aussi à l'ensemble des femmes du
monde
première étape et d'un long chemin versa
possible constitutionnalisation
si sur le papier le droit à l'avortement
semble acquis son accès est-il garanti
partout sur le territoire
comment sont prises en charge les femmes
l'IVG est-elle un acte médical comme un
autre
[Musique]
le planning familial bonjour
et je pense que je pense que voilà j'ai
enceinte et j'aimerais procéder en fait
à une VGM médicamenteux et donc vous
avez combien de jours de retard
aujourd'hui
elle souhaite réaliser une IVG par
aspiration ça sera directement vers
l'hôpital qu'il faudra se diriger vers
les centres IVG des hôpitaux
ouais alors elle pourra se tourner vers
le service social de l'hôpital qui
pourra lui prendre en charge son
avortement
au planning familial de Paris les
conseillères conjugales reçoivent les
appels et oriente les femmes qui
souhaitent mettre fin à leur grossesse
qui viennent au planning familial pour
demander un avortement parce que les
personnes savent que ça va être un lieu
bienveillant ou elles vont pouvoir se
sentir bien être à l'écoute non jugé un
aqueux non culpabilisant aussi
les femmes trouvent ici une écoute à
aucun moment on ne leur demande pourquoi
elles font ce choix on ne juge pas leur
décision
jusqu'à cette semaine de grossesse elles
peuvent choisir la méthode diriger
médicamenteuse ou instrumentale
au planning la médecin réalise les IVG
médicamenteuses une conseillère les
accompagne
vous êtes arrivés après vous vous avez
déjà fait rapidement datation non
d'accord vous non plus vous n'avez pas
fait donc il y a encore trois à passer
ok alors le groupe et on en discutera
réellement après ça sera quand vous
aurez fait la l'échographie de datation
après l'examen avec le médecin les
femmes sont reçues en groupe c'est un
temps d'échange avant la mise en place
du protocole et la prise des médicaments
qui entraîneront la fausse couche
ce jour-là elles n'ont pas accepté la
présence de notre caméra même
anonymement s'il est autorisé depuis
près de 50 ans l'avortement reste tabou
[Musique]
la question est pas si simple et assez
tabou ouais alors il y a quelques
milieux où ça les plus mais en règle
générale j'ai quand même l'impression
que ça reste assez tabou on n'a pas
envie d'en parler
encore une femme qui disait je suis
allée voir ma gynécologue
la première réaction c'est
félicitations c'est une bonne nouvelle
donc finalement pour plein de femmes ce
n'est pas une quoi
et on culpabilise encore les femmes de
ne pas se réjouir de grossesse
on n'arrête pas les culpabiliser
c'est de leur faute ça aurait pu faire
attention
c'est vrai que même maintenant avec la
contraception qui existe vraiment
comment on joue pour être enceinte
une partie des femmes qui viennent au
planning familial sont envoyés par leur
généraliste ou leur gynécologue car tout
médecin a le droit de refuser de
pratiquer l'IVG c'est la clause de
conscience
on a connu ça il y a les gynécologues
ils disent plus que il le disent pas
qu'ils ont une prise de conscience c'est
affiché nulle part ils sont pas obligés
de le dire
mais on a énormément de femmes qui
viennent faire des avortements ou qu'on
a au téléphone et qu'on oriente parce
qu'elles sont allées voir leur
gynécologue ou un gynécologue ou une
gynécologue d'ailleurs femme ou homme
c'est pareil
qui leur a dit que non il faisait pas
n'importe comment
donc c'est une manière détourner mais en
fait c'est pas ils disent pas qu'ils
sont contre mais ils font pas
là cet après-midi la gynéco lui a dit
que ben non elle était pas elle était
pas habilité à faire
3% seulement tes gynécologues et des
médecins en cabinet pratiquent l'IVG
[Musique]
les femmes doivent alors se tourner vers
l'hôpital ou le planning familial depuis
60 ans ici on lutte pour le droit à la
contraception et à l'avortement et
aujourd'hui pour sa
constitutionnalisation pour sa
Présidente il y a un vrai danger qui
plane sur l'IVG il y a toujours eu des
anti choix mais aujourd'hui ils ont des
ils ont gagné des batailles aux
États-Unis ils ont gagné en Hongrie ils
ont gagné en Italie ils vont gagner
sûrement encore donc il faut qu'on soit
hyper vigilante et de se dire que
pourquoi en France ça serait une
exception c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
il faut vraiment faire en sorte que ça
soit un droit fondamental d'essayer de
le protéger un maximum en même temps de
le rendre effectif parce que cette
bataille là elle est toujours au
quotidien pour le planning et pour les
associations féministes mais en tout cas
il y a en effet quelque chose à faire et
puis de constitutionnaliser l'avortement
en France on serait le premier
et en fait ça résonnerait dans le monde
entier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
par leur victoire aux États-Unis et en
Hongrie les anti avortements donnent de
la voix ce dimanche là depuis 2005 ces
catholiques conservateurs et
traditionnels organisent une
manifestation à Paris la Marche pour la
vie il défile tous les ans autour de
l'anniversaire de la loi veille
à leur tête leur porte-parole Aliette
espieux depuis deux ans elle a pris les
rênes de la manifestation
elle est plus que jamais mobilisée
contre la constitutionnalisation de
l'IVG
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose de dramatique et de
vraiment pervers de la part du
gouvernement c'est que l'article 66 1 de
la Constitution
interdit aboli la peine de mort et
l'article qui suivra sera donc
l'autorisation de mettre à mort des
enfants et c'est là où il y a un énorme
paradoxe c'est quand on interdit on
interdit la peine de mort pour les
criminels pour les violeurs pour les
pédophiles et à côté de ça on va dire
mais en fait un enfant selon la
situation selon le contexte dans lequel
il a attendu ben on peut le tuer
celle qui a rajeuni et modernisé le
mouvement espère bien abolir la loi
veille
moi je souhaite envoyer un deuxième
signal au monde entier celui d'une
France réveillée
une France héroïque prête à tout pour
refermer cette boîte de Pandore ouverte
par Simone Veil
la bataille se joue aussi en coulisses
ces opposants à l'avortement s'infiltre
jusqu'au parlement pendant les débats
sur la constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
la députée Pascale Martin portait la
parole de son groupe dans l'hémicycle
quelques jours avant les débats elle a
reçu une lettre particulière
l'avortement n'est pas un droit abstrait
mais un acte sanglant par lequel il est
mis fin à la vie d'un être humain tel
que le fœtus de 12 semaines que vous
tenez entre les mains pensez-vous
sincère que cet acte soit un droit
fondamental ayant sa place dans la
Constitution voilà donc ils sont
persuadés que un fœtus c'est un être
humain et qu'il a des droits d'êtres
humains comme s'il était déjà
en vie ce type de courrier moi ça m'a
mis assez en colère voilà après il y a
un sentiment de dégoût parce que ça joue
sur
sur le visuel évidemment
donc moi je connaissais pas cette
organisme tout de suite on s'est
renseigné on a vu à qui on avait affaire
cet organisme c'est le centre européen
pour le droit et la justice une
association conservatrice chrétienne
très active au Parlement européen il y a
tout un lobby autour de ça qui est
vraiment
insupportable mais ça veut aussi dire
qu'ils ont de l'argent et que derrière
il y a des gens qui les financent et
voilà donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
vraiment être en résistance parce que
ça peut tout à fait demain basculer vers
quelque chose que je ne souhaite pas et
que des millions de femmes ne souhaitent
pas
pour faire interdire l'avortement
l'association ne se contente pas
d'envoyer des lettres au parlementaire
ce jour-là avant l'examen de la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG au Sénat
elle est invitée par le sénateur
d'extrême droite Stéphane Ravier
ancien cadre du rassemblement national
passer depuis chez Éric Zemmour c'est un
fervent opposant à la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
pour aborder ce débat sur la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG plutôt
que de céder ou encore une fois aux
passions vous exigences de des individus
des individualités j'ai souhaité que
nous étions le débat qui viennent débat
déjà parce que c'est très difficile
d'avoir un débat sur ce sujet et que
nous élevions le débat avec des
personnalités des professeurs qui
je dirais
dépolluer de toute considération
artisanes justement pourtant les quatre
conférences qui est invitées sont tous
fermement opposés à cette
constitutionnalisation à l'image de
Grégor pupinc le président du Centre
Européen pour le droit et la justice
celui qui envoie des lettres aux députés
l'avortement on voit bien fait mal ce
n'est pas un concept ni une liberté
abstraite mais une réalité dure
l'avortement ne sera jamais un véritable
droit humain mais seulement une
violation ou une dérogation au droit au
respect de la vie nous sommes tous ici
là des universitaires enseignants
docteurs nous écrirons des livres des
articles de scientifiques donc ce n'est
pas du lobbying que de donner une
analyse juridique une analyse
sociologique sur ce sujet
aucun sénateur n'a répondu à
l'invitation deux jours plus tard le
Sénat votait pour la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
[Musique]
loin du combat politique le droit à
l'avortement reste fragile sur le
terrain victime des déserts médicaux et
des choix de santé publique en 2023
l'accès à l'IVG est inégal
en 20 ans 130 maternités ont fermé et
avec elle la possibilité pour les femmes
d'avorter
c'est l'histoire de Rethel dans les
Ardennes une ville de 8000 habitants à
45 km de reins
en 2010 la maternité ferme ses portes le
Centre périnatal n'assure plus que les
suivis de grossesse il faudra attendre
2016 et l'engagement du docteur Odile
Maurice pour que les femmes aient à
nouveau accès à l'IVG
[Musique]
c'est une population qui est très rurale
souvent alors
niveau socio et économique bien sûr bas
avec des difficultés de transport enfin
c'est des souvent c'est des patients qui
ont pas de voiture
qui conduisent pas dans les maris des
fois ne sont pas véhicules et non plus
ou sont donc l'avantage d'avoir la
consultation sur place et qu'elles
peuvent être un peu plus autonomes et
moi j'ai vu à l'époque où
c'était pas possible à Rethel ou même
quand des fois je suis pas là des
patientes garder leurs grossesse parce
qu'elle pouvait pas venir jusqu'à Reims
faire leur interruption de grossesse
c'est important d'avoir la possibilité
d'avoir le choix ou pas de garder une
grossesse
je ne défends pas l'IVG à tout prix mais
je défends le droit au choix
dans de bonnes conditions
[Musique]
médecin au CHU de Reims Odile Maurice
vient ici tous les vendredis
elle assure les consultations et prend
en charge les IVG chirurgicales par
aspiration pour les femmes qui le
souhaitent et pour celles qui ont
dépassé les 7 semaines de grossesse
c'est alors la seule méthode possible
21 ans
vous êtes en couple
ça fait combien de temps
ça se passe bien il est gentil pas de
violence
en fait j'étais chez mon médecin d'abord
pour quelques symptômes qui du coup il
m'a conseillé d'aller faire une prise de
sang et j'ai été en faire une et j'ai eu
les résultats soi-même du coup
j'étais un peu stressé quand même quoi
enfin c'est pas c'est pas nous d'un coup
j'ai déjà eu assez de mal pour avoir un
rendez-vous parce que de base j'avais
déjà appelé Charleville Charleville
m'ont dit qu'il pouvait pas avant un
certain temps combien de temps du coup
Charleville c'était pas avant deux
semaines c'est quand même plus pratique
de savoir assez rapidement quand même
parce que j'étais déjà assez comment
dire loin dans la grossesse donc voilà
vous êtes pas loin dans la grossesse
d'accord
franchement vous êtes dans les délais il
y a pas de non non
Laura est à 9 semaines de grossesse par
rapport à l'âge de la grossesse
la méthode possible c'est la méthode
instrumentale au bloc opératoire vous
avez lu sur la feuille vous avez vu
comment ça se passait avec deux
possibilités soit sous anesthésie
générale ou vous dormez complètement
soit sous anesthésie locale ou on endort
juste la zone où on passe les
instruments non il faut savoir que c'est
pas complètement sans douleur
que vous les ressentir un certain nombre
de choses
nous retrouverons le rat pour son
opération quelques jours plus tard sans
la présence du médecin à Rethel son
parcours aurait été plus compliqué plus
d'attente et de kilomètres pour pouvoir
interrompre sa grossesse pour proposer
plus de consultations les sages-femmes
de Rethel se sont formés depuis deux ans
elles prennent en charge les IVG
médicamenteuses une quarantaine chaque
année
avait déjà suivi Aurélie pour une
grossesse elle l'accompagne aujourd'hui
pour son avortement
[Musique]
heureusement que ça existe parce que
sinon
[Musique]
c'est compliqué vous avez pu en parler
autour de vous moi il y a que mon mari
est au courant mais sinon personne
d'autre
professionnel pour se confirme un petit
peu parce que sinon c'est dur en fait
[Applaudissements]
généralement après la prise de ce
premier médicament là
la plupart du temps il se passe rien de
particulier il est très important de
prendre 24 à 48 heures après les deux
autres d'accord comme on est juste au
dessus de cette semaine à minorée c'est
deux comprimés à prendre si jamais voilà
vous êtes inquiète si tout compte fait
ça a beau être noté on ne labo avoir
abordé si c'est pas clair vous savez
plus trop n'hésitez pas à appeler il y
aura toujours un médecin au bout du fil
pour vous répondre OK
le délai de prise en charge des femmes
et de 5 jours
ici comme partout en France l'accès à
l'avortement est avant tout une histoire
d'engagement des professionnels
depuis un an la loi permet aux
sages-femmes de pratiquer les IVG
chirurgicales c'est l'une des pistes
pour garantir l'accès à l'avortement
mais elle n'est toujours pas effective
faute de décret d'application mot en
tout cas est prête à s'y former
si nouvelle compétences compétences je
m'en saisirais certains s'il y a pas le
docteur Maurice
dans les années on sait jamais
ça serait une offre au moins
parce que je vois pas à l'heure actuelle
qui qui pourrait la remplacer pour l'IVG
chongical alors même si effectivement
les trois quarts des IVG comme réalisé
actuellement sont des visions
médicamentseuses on a quand même des
fois il y a besoin de l'autre méthode et
oui je pense que c'est important parce
que ça va clairement
permettre de réduire les inégalités
d'accès sur le territoire ça c'est
certain parce que on est quand même
26000 en France
former et spécialiser les soignants dans
ce domaine c'est l'objectif du Diplôme
Universitaire de régulation des
naissances à Paris Nathalie trignole
enseigne et transmet son expérience
auprès de futurs médecins et de
sage-femme
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
c'est simplement la situation d'une
femme qui est fertile qui a eu un
rapport sexuel et qui se trouve enceinte
à un moment où c'est pas le moment pour
elle et donc il y a une différence entre
la possibilité d'être enceinte et le
désir d'être mère et il y a plus de
grossesse qui surviennent de façon
inopinée que ce qu'on pense et parmi ces
grossesses qui apparaissent de façon
inopinée il y en a un tiers qui vont
être interrompu ces élèves viennent
approfondir leurs connaissances sur cet
acte délaissé de la médecine du coup
c'est abordé dans nos études plus la
contraception que l'IVG selon moi mais
je trouve que c'est survolé ça nous
donne pas les outils pour en pratique
pouvoir répondre de manière adaptée et
complète à la demande des patients
au-delà de la technique médicale ils
sont sensibilisés à l'accueil des femmes
c'est ce qui a poussé calistine à se
former l'une des patientes qu'elles suit
a été traumatisée par un psychologue
en fait elle lui avait demandé mais en
fait j'ai peur de ce qui va sortir de
moi qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que je vais
voir en fait après l'IVG et il lui avait
répondu vous verrez pas grand chose vous
allez perdre un petit œuf mais il y aura
deux points noirs et ce sera les yeux de
votre conscience
et en fait du coup cette patiente n'a
pas réalisé cet IVG et là elle revenait
du coup dans le cadre d'une grossesse
du coup
qu'elle ne souhaitait pas garder parce
que c'était un contexte très compliqué
avec son conjoint avec sa situation
professionnelle etc qu'elle avait déjà
quatre enfants
et elles me disait je ne peux pas le
garder je ne veux pas mais j'ai peur de
ces deux points noirs que je verrai et
c'est une phrase qu'elle avait entendu
10 ans auparavant mais finalement elle a
gardé cette grossesse et
ben voilà et j'aurais aimé être là il y
a 10 ans pour lui dire tout va bien se
passer
le regard des autres le jugement ses
professionnels ils sont eux-mêmes
confrontés on sent quand même de la part
de certains collègues
quelque chose de l'ordre de pourquoi tu
fais ça
un peu c'est pas du soin en fait c'est
pas considéré parfois comme ouais comme
du soin ou comme intéressant
intellectuellement ou comme
voilà c'est faut bien qu'il y ait des
gens qui le fassent donc tant mieux que
toi tu t'en occupes mais voilà c'est
jamais dit complètement frontalement
mais c'est pas valorisé non pas du tout
quand on s'intéresse à la question et
qu'on est soignant et qu'on est dans
l'humain et qu'on est dans l'empathie et
qu'on a envie d'aider les autres mais je
comprends pas comment on peut être
soignant humain faire de la médecine des
femmes et ne pas considérer que
l'avortement c'est la base on est ravi
de voir que dans la jeune génération il
y a une relève qui qui arrive pour ce
chant de la médecine
un retail nous retrouvons au bloc
opératoire Laura la patiente du docteur
Maurice
la jeune femme a choisi l'anesthésie
locale
[Musique]
ça va vous êtes assez confortable
je vais commencer l'anesthésie
voilà
c'est super
c'est fini ça va ouais ça a été comment
je vous embête pas là on va vous
remettre correctement
du coup la douleur entre 0 et 10 c'était
à combien au maximum
l'intervention a duré 15 minutes
depuis qu'elle est pratiquée de manière
légale l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse est en danger pour la santé ou
la fertilité des femmes
vous avez une petite collation ça y est
oui d'accord la douleur là c'est comment
maintenant
vous avez vérifié les saignements ça
c'est normalement un petit peu ok c'est
une page qui se tourne pour Laura un
événement dans sa vie de femme auquel
elle donnera la place qu'elle souhaite
je me sens rassurée soulagée surtout je
m'attendais vraiment à petit et en fait
ça a été je trouve c'était surtout
angoissant en fait parce que je savais
pas quoi m'attendre donc comment dire
déjà je vais bien dormir parce que
j'arrivais plus du tout à dormir je
pensais beaucoup donc
c'était compliqué et puis ouais non je
pense que ça ira mieux tu auras à peu
près tout
une vie normale
un accueil bienveillant dans des délais
raisonnables le choix de la méthode
c'est ce que garantit en théorie la loi
il reste encore des étapes avant que le
droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse ne soit peut-être inscrit dans
la Constitution il faudra soit un
référendum soit que les députés et les
sénateurs se réunissent en congrès à
Versailles
quel qu'en soit l'issue les
professionnels et les femmes espèrent
avant tout un meilleur accès à l'IVG
partout en France
[Musique]